would you rather any other Charlie's
Angels dick
I gotta go with Debbie man she's just
right amount of nods nah it looks like
we might have to spend the night here
baby talking door hello door is
everybody on the calculator yeah I went
outside I saw doulas car plugged in
price of gas is five dollars a gallon
what's the date 2016 that when we smoke
knocked us out for 30 years
Debbie you guys want me to believe you
bought some superhot from area 51 I'm
your waiter will concert that you never
got to because your van fell into a
ditch where you slept for 30 years and
here you are that is what really
happened - who is this guy thanks Brad
that's Debbie's kid I said I didn't want
you to meet my son I understand the
whole thing about Roma
no drugs he'll be very respectful that's
how pretty your hair looks with the gray
in it
Jesus Christ - tea - tea - Ellie
you really need to work on your
compliments
that smoke cigarettes we're green and
those are our two o'clock if you're
ghosts how come I can't see through you
[Music]
he's playing the music he's aging the
song has changed and his arms were in
the air is he DJing with his dick he's a
dick jockey
you